hello everyone welcome welcome to pi
data global 2021 my name is flynn
ressler i'm
your chair for your session feel free
to kind of rename you in this session i
hope everybody is comfortable
and i'm looking forward to this session
the first session we have in this blog
is
with i hope i said that correctly hoda
rezai
energy solution lead at in
integra data analytics solution and
she'll be talking about innovating in
the oil and gas industry with ainml
hoda is a strategic thinker focused on
adding value to the oil gas industry she
has a passion for data and analytics
with a great understanding for business
processes pain points and constraints
in collaboration with her data science
team she has
delivered many successful projects so
i'm very excited to welcome you today
huda has asked that questions shall wait
till the finish so without further ado
over to you
thanks for the introduction florin i'm
just going to start
sharing my screen
i'm
i'm really excited to be here and
present to you um innovating in the oil
and gas with ai and machine learning
this has been a really exciting journey
since i started in the oil and gas with
an engineering background and transition
into data science and now um i'm just
happy to share whatever we found out
during this journey with with our
community open source and oil and gas um
just a
little bit of agenda of today's talk i'm
going to do a really quick introduction
and then we move on to ai anal adoption
in the oil and gas industry and i after
that i will be sharing with you some of
the use cases that we have done some of
the outcomes and then i leave the floor
open to to discussions and questions
um so at integra we are a group of
engineers and computer scientists uh our
focus and main goal is to equip
enterprises and individuals with the
most advanced technologies and
methodologies so they're able to solve
their real world operational challenges
in the oil and gas industry we recently
were acquired by a data analytics
software and service company called now
vertical which is which the mission is
uh to help them to help the clients then
in the digital economy
um
now let's uh move uh move on to to the
analytics gap in the oil and gas
industry these main roadblocks that we
see in developing analytics pollution
and oil and gas industries slow down the
aiml adoption project success and roi
and the organizations
one of the main roadblocks is data data
is scattered and filled across many
applications it is usually processed
manually which increases the stop
contamination and human error working
with the data in a manual process is
consuming the productive time of
engineers data is under utilized
and rarely trans transmitted
interactionable insights
processes in the oil and gas industry
they don't scale to current and that you
need are highly manual and inefficient
and are not repeatable
and not designed for analytics which
brings us to the next roadblock which is
analytics itself it's
um what we call analytics
today is more metric driven as opposed
to insight driven there are many
dashboards many graphs that is created
but limited insight is generated is
generated out of those and these
insights are not integrated into
business processes
it comes to technology
existing technology is very complex in
the form of legacy software there are
they're very costly and um very hard to
implement and the licensing model is
usually makes it very hard to scale to
to the whole organization
they like flexibility when it comes to
the innovation are not designed to fit
into different skills and expertise
levels
it's very hard to think out of the box
when we're using these
these legacy softwares
but how
integral is actually
um filling these gaps and how we have
learned to tackle some of these
roadblocks and these challenges
and i think i would believe in a
collaborative methodology and delivering
repeatable aimr solutions across a broad
range of use cases
this end-to-end methodology brings a
different dimension in decision-making
this will take data-driven decision
making to a completely different level
where the right data is used and
utilized to generate insights and make
an impact into the way that everyday
work is done
well the impact of this methodology is
reduced cost reduced risk proven return
on investment improved safety and
reducing uh the environmental impact
which is very important nowadays
um now how do we align the business uh
and analytics projects
so we find we need to find the main pain
points and uh just the few examples we
have here are uh in the areas of
predictive maintenance pipeline
integrity health and safety process
optimization and production optimization
and we we try to
solve these pain points with analytics
when it comes to
to analytics data is everything we want
to maintain a single source of the truth
across the application for the entire
end-to-end solution we should limit the
data movement through applications
through users
so we eliminate the risk of
contamination which is a which is a very
huge risk when it comes to the data we
need to prepare the data to be able to
use it
uh for analytics and um
these data comes in different formats it
comes in different frequencies and it
has to be integrated and
properly engineered uh
for for delivering a successful data
science project
we we wanted solutions to be
repeatable um we want them to be to be
we want to be able to scale them we want
everyone across the organization to be
used to be able to use this solution
and as part of our commitment to data
science and oil and gas community we
have developed some of the common
um solutions for the oil and gas
industry in the form of these repeatable
nozzle samplers that you have on our uh
our platform digital hub which i'm going
to talk about it and the technology um
we have developed a platform a data
science platform using open source
components
um which which hosts many applications
for data science and business
intelligence and these repeatable
workflows
using open source will eliminate the
cost of licensing and inability to scale
um leveraging our platform we put the
highest grade application security and
computation in the hands of enterprises
across the industry and with digital hub
self-service capabilities
we are actually bridging the gap between
ip and business
um
and with that i'm going to uh kind of
talk about some of the use cases that we
have developed for the middle stream and
upstream oil and gas these are just
examples of what what could be done what
is the art of possible when it comes to
uh analytics applications in the oil and
gas industry and what are the outcomes
um i'm going to
uh deep dive in one of these use cases
just show you how we approach the
problem how we identify the pain points
and what are the outcomes and of an
innovative solution in in the industry
so this pipeline failure simulation is a
like an innovative approach to
forecasting pipeline failure
um it is um it is very critical to
identify the defects and identify
uh the main problematic areas in the
pipeline early enough so python
engineers are able to make this repair
and big decisions for these defects in a
timely manner
um poe is the most critical factor for
different disease integrity decision
making it's the probability that the
corrosion defect detected and sized by
an inline inspection tool exceeds the
industry um criteria and leads to a
failure
now um this theory has been
traditionally um calculated using a
deterministic statistical method and
that's how
in this in this approach
it's they use the average of these
measurements and these variations they
don't take into account the
uncertainties and the measurements when
it comes to the ili and the errors and
the reporting of the the inline
respection and the variations in the
pythagorean
specifications
growth models uh across the pipelines
are different based on the environment
based on the type of product that is
moving through the pipeline based on
the size of the pipeline but
uh what has been used traditionally is a
really generic corrosion and linear
corrosion model which does not reflect
uh the reality of the growth of these
corrosion defects in the python it is
not computationally optimized for larger
life files
i guess very costly and very um
complicated if if you want to run this
solution for the entire pipeline with
many features and it's it's hard to
scale um there are many pipelines out
there with many features and if if you
want to
um kind of uh scale this solution to
this entire system it would get very
complicated and sometimes
it's impossible but
having this accurate poe is very
important um to reduce the chance of
pipeline incidents eliminate the
unnecessary
repairs and
go and actually pay attention to the
sections of the python that are more
problematic and need immediate attention
so
um having an accurate poe will bring
visibility to integrity engineers and so
they can make these entirety decisions
which are which are very expensive
decisions um uh with backed by data on
analytics now
what integral has done is we leveraged
the monte carlo markov chain simulation
model to
to create to generate a poe distribution
based on all these variations in the
pipeline and the in the measurement
tools and in the environment of the
pipeline and we bring all of them
together in forms of the distribution
and feed it to the monte carlo markov
chain model so we're able to generate um
a
scenario for poe and with generating
millions of millions of simulation we
are actually able to have a better
understanding of
what is the most possible um poe
poe ranges for the for the specific
defect
so we we use
we leverage class computing for
scalability and for a large amount of
poe simulation we can just
easily run this
and it can be run within
for the entire pipeline system
um just an example um in less than six
hours
we ran the simulation for 300 corrosion
defects and 10 million stimulation 10 10
years for a cat
um here you can see some some of the
graphs that um just uh i just put here
so you can see the outcome here on the
on the left um
you see the poe distribution for for one
defect and one feature so you can see
that how it's distributed across a range
and when when you're making the decision
you have a range in mind about what poe
could be could possibly be and then the
depth of the defect which is very
important factor in making the
repair decisions also as presented here
in form of a distribution
and these traps on the right um they
show the 10-year forecast so for a
particular feature how
feature is going to grow and how much of
this um
how much of the metal is going to be
lost during this 10 years so
and this is the probability of accident
for these features based on their size
and based on their location on the
pipeline and this is um so clear that
you can see okay when they're going to
um
exceed the threshold of the criteria
that we have set for them so you know
for example here you have five years or
four years to do the repair and um
and then you can plan your integrity
activities based on that
now
um throughout these years and throughout
this journey we've learned ever learned
so much we
uh we have come to these uh to these
points that can set us
up for success when it comes to
delivering data science projects in
industry and these are not specific to
oil and gas they can be applied to to
any industry
um first thing first is you need to have
a clear understanding of the problem
that you're trying to solve what is is
it a time failure a problem you're
solving is it a
energy management problem is it a
pipeline integrity so you have to have a
clear understanding
of the problem and then
you have to have the business outcomes
in mind okay what is it
what is it going to how is it going to
impact the business is it going to
reduce my risk is it going to reduce my
cost
and then you have to set um your goals
goals should be reachable add and
address the largest economic
opportunities that fits your
organization infrastructure data people
and process capacities
um
then you have to have access to the
right data and technology so
take the right size of data pick the
right frequency of data if your
pond or your event is happening every
three months you don't need to look at
three years of data that just makes the
process complicated and your time to
value and your time to generate insight
longer
um you need to
use the existing technologies don't base
time and resources on building uh
complicated technical solutions or uh
tackle too much data which requires a
lot of like infrastructure and
computations to to deliver the solution
um
you have to be able to pivot quickly you
have to be flexible to redirect your
product
if you think something is not working or
it's not a problem and you you need to
be able to pivot to a json problem or
from upstream or downstream just to be
able to
to show to show the results and these
analytics and data initiatives must
yield results almost immediately and
continuously in order to create the
necessary momentum
and support across organizations
um i usually say a need for a speed
approach um can help you move attraction
really quickly
and get the support that you need from
the organization
well and then it brings us to the fail
uh failing part don't be afraid to fail
early right uh you might find out that
this is not the solution
uh it's not feasible and this is not the
problem that i want to focus on and
that's that's very um that's very good
to happen in earlier stages of the
problem before you actually dedicate a
lot of time and resources to a problem
that is not worth
solving
and be agile it's uh it's very important
that you implement the solutions using
agile methodologies
well avoid filing for waterfalls
methodologies um it's it's best to use
uh iterative approaches and deliver
valuable values incrementally and in a
stages
um through these ideal methodologies you
develop a business case and create a
roadmap for implementing the insight and
then adopt this strategy based on your
business needs and capacity so it's very
important to be agile and and small and
start a small a breakdown if you if you
come across a really big problem break
it down into smaller pieces and
um tackle them one by one for example
start with one pump if you want to do
the predictive maintenance on your pump
start with one pump solve it for that
one and then you can scale it to to the
entire pump station um
but when you have the insights you can
build on it and you can bring in more
data and more factors
into your decision making
one of the most important
lessons that we've learned is that we
need to have uh the support of saginaw
experts they are the ones who are
actually dealing with these problems and
every day they have they come across
these challenges and they have to solve
them and they entirely know the process
they know the technical style they know
the business and it's very important to
onboard them and validate the insights
with them
um
it's it's just um it's just good to have
frequent touch points to them so they
are on board and um our model also
should be simple so they they understand
it clearly
and then um
the the ones that were actually going to
um use your solution and take that
inside and
turn it into action are the end users
um once you generate your insights um
you at the beginning you're only dealing
with the front line of the business the
operator someone who's actually doing
the the work and they have to be on
board they have to be um they have to be
engaged continuously to to make this
this project successful
and they have to be able to adapt to the
change they have to have time and they
have to have proper information and
instructions to adapt to that this
change but that's going to change their
everyday
work
um
and then the alkaline outcomes which is
very important we have to have the
business value in mind and every step of
these projects that we deliver
um what are we going to achieve in the
end as it's
reducing cost is it improving um
experience is it reducing risk is it uh
increasing the throughput and the
production so
with we're having a clear outcome and a
and a business value driven
um project you can have the business
decision makers and end users on board
with you that makes that makes your
project successful
so i think i think this is on my side uh
florian i
i handed up to you uh for any questions
excellent thank you so much there was a
great talk we have already a few
questions in here
um so
i don't know uh you can check as well
the q a but other than that i'll uh
start off with uh
from houston he's asking uh for the
corrosion effect defects within
pipelines there are several factors that
influence corrosion like flow flow
medium pipeline material contaminants
etc how did you generalize this to
predict failure
so um we actually use the variables that
we have in hand and then this is a good
point and this is a good question
that you you you asked um
how i'm gonna answer this is
so we we actually defined
uh models and distribution for each of
the input variables so when it comes to
this the monte carlo markov chain
stimulation we we had we had to deal
with two different uh variables one of
them were constant variables and the
other one
um the ones that had a distribution so
we
based on the data that we had right we
picked the uh the distribution for any
of those variables that we were able to
for example we paste a distribution for
the the depth of the defect you take
distribution for
uh the maop which is the maximum
operating pressure in the pipeline
um
but some of them were constant so
um
there are
some of these variables that we had to
input to the simulation had a constant
value that we weren't able to find a
distribution for them
but um what is good about this um this
simulation is that it's flexible when it
comes to the inputs
so for if you have a um
and your data in your organization right
you have access to the distribution of
any of these variables you can easily
adjust the model and have the input as a
distribution so you can you're taking
into account that variations and those
um um those differences in the
measurements
uh but we you need to work with whatever
you have right if you don't have the
distribution just feed them out of the
constant value
excellent thank you i hope uh this
answers
your questions
um i'm gonna
allow ragu to talk so maybe you can ask
your question yourself um
i think otherwise i'm happy to also uh
hi uh
i'm from traditional engineering
a lot of convincing to be done for the
effort to show the benefit of data
science and data analytics to executive
and management so i was just curious
like how did you overcome the
communication barriers in a traditional
engineering or like old school mindset
uh kind of workplace
yeah
well that's a very good question and i i
believe this is the most challenging
part when it comes to uh to start a data
transparency sort of an initiative in
the oil and gas industry um there are
many ways it depends who you are
actually uh talking to right if it's if
you're talking with the with the it team
um it's different how you approach it
and how you position your project uh as
opposed to when you're talking to
technical teams because these uh like
these groups they have their own
concerns and they have their own um
their own strategies and all of them are
valid so you need to be able to
propose something that is going to help
them within uh what they're doing every
day without interrupting any of their
services and without um causing any uh
like more pains uh as opposed to like
the improvements right and that's
what what i have usually uh
found out if what i found out is that
it's it's very easier when you go uh
and and present to them something that
has already been done
so if you come if you want to solve a
problem you need to go and find examples
that other people have done it that
tremendously helps just to inform them
and um kind of bring that thought
leadership into the organization just to
show them examples of okay yeah i've
i've come across this uh this palm
failure modeling this is similar to what
we have this is similar to a problem
that and this is how they have solved it
and don't forget to
uh to always uh mention the business
value now how is it gonna help us okay
this is gonna help us reduce our repair
costs this is gonna help us reduce our
production shutdown because of the the
maintenance right so
when you when you take this approach
this is uh this is usually
helpful
um it's not guaranteed but um
but it's been it's been a challenge and
i think it's it's always gonna be a
challenge
thank you we had a question similar um
by sheila okay
um she said it's similar so uh robert
meyer would you like to ask you a
question live or should i read it out
i'll give you a second to unmute if you
want
i think
can you hear me all right
yes we can okay great um i i work in a
rather similar space so we are a startup
in in cement and concrete so
your journey feels feels quite similar
so i'm curious like how often do
analytics and ml projects actually get
stuck in pilot purgatory and never make
it into production in oil and gas
um
well
oil i guess is is still a little bit in
the earlier stages of these like the ai
animal adoption right
and there's been some of the
organizations actually really advanced
they have data science um
organization within their within their
enterprises
they have community of practices they
have analytics um
um kind of departments
um and they have been they have been
identifying many of these use cases and
add addition to their portfolio as as we
see them in the predictive maintenance
and the production optimization but um
you're bringing a good point that some
of these um
projects are stuck in the poc
um
because it's it's um sometimes i find
that it's hard to to justify the cost to
develop that uh
the poc and move from the poc uh kind of
stage to the production
um when it comes to the business value
it's hard to justify the cost of
deployment and that's why we we need to
be really careful and and um
kind of when we are developing these
solutions that they have to have the
business value and uh has to have a
quick time to value and
we have to prove the return of
investment and that's why most of these
products they can move out of the coc
because
it's hard to scale and it's hard to
justify the cost
and maybe we have three minutes left um
roxanna would you like to ask your
question as well
yes hi could you speak about how you
approached limiting data movement and
data automation because i assume you use
a lot of sensors and they might they
must store information in multiple
sources and formats so i'm curious about
the data the limiting data aspect
okay
that's a really great uh great question
roxpanna it's uh so in our platform
digital hub
we have actually implemented a single
source of the tools on the platform so
in every project that you start in a
digital hub platform
once you have the data and the project
it will never have to move
that environment so you do all your
analysis on development if you want to
do a machine learning or time series or
what analysis that you want to do on
your data you will do it on the platform
and then it's accessible through
let's say your bi and visualization
application and the platform so you
don't have to move the data around you
don't have to push it to different data
data storages and shared folders just to
be able to access through your
visualization that you want to share
your outcomes right and that's um that's
what we we want to limit the movement of
the data and just be
able to maintain the single source of
the truth
thank you very much our time
unfortunately is like on the spot we
have one minute to go so thanks again
very much hoda and um yeah enjoy the
rest of the conference
thank you
thanks everyone